next question today is from Diane Diane
says aren't both conservatives and
liberals reacting badly to the election
um yeah well yeah I mean you could look
at a few different uh term data points
to talk about this I think that there
are different ways in which some
progressives and some conservatives are
reacting badly to the selection on the
progressive side there's two critiques
to be made and it mostly relates to the
anti-trump protests but it can be
applied also to progressive ideology and
answered statements about the next four
years number one uh any violence and
we've seen some violence at anti-trump
protests violence and destruction of
property no bad not only is it is it bad
at its face for the obvious reasons it
also plays in directly to the Trump
'used narrative and it exposes
progressives two more critique and that
that is really really bad and
additionally as we talked about earlier
this week the article by italian luigi
zingales he made the point that you know
we had the election and presumably the
election was legitimate although were
sort of looking into it in some states
uh to criticize Trump now when he hasn't
actually done anything yes he started to
express what he plans to do as president
of the United States but he hasn't
actually done anything yet it's number
one sort of a boy who cried wolf thing
you want to be able to actually critique
him aggressively and forcefully when he
starts doing stuff but also you need to
be critiquing trump on issues and not on
sort of identity related ideas and i've
said the same thing so i think that that
would be sort of a bad reaction or a
less-than-ideal reaction from
progressive to Donald Trump's election
win however there are also many
conservatives who have reacted not well
to Donald Trump's win now at a very sort
of basic and not a big deal level we saw
these conservatives who would go into
Starbucks and demand that they put Trump
on the cups because at many Starbucks
they announced the name of the person
whose order is ready and they wanted to
say Trump and some starbucks employees
refused and then a pro Trump
boycott of starbucks started this is
just not only stupid but it's also kind
of being a sore winner I mean what
what's the point of that and the the
racist comments and is Anna phobic
comment that have resulted from that by
many pro Trumper's is absolutely uh
despicable but also there have been many
conservatives who have just wrongly
reacted to Trump's victory thinking that
it's a mandate and some of them are
using that to just sort of a tout their
their bigoted views and we've seen a lot
of videos of that Saint Trump won hey
based on your skin color you go back to
whatever country etc etc the horrible
reaction but it's also an inaccurate
reaction because Donald Trump having
lost the popular vote by millions of
votes to Hillary Clinton actually has
sort of like the biggest non mandate
that we've seen in a very long time so
not only is it off-putting an offensive
and nonsensical for the Trump supporters
to be a sort of puffing their chests out
in that way it also isn't justified by
the numbers and you could argue that
kind of behavior never would be but hey
if your guy won by seven million votes
and actually trounced Clinton in the
electoral vote sort of a different story
than pretending that the Trump ideology
overwhelmingly won it actually lost when
it comes to the number of voters and I
think that's something really important
to keep in mind Diane